ذكرت في البدايه انه هناك فريق طبي مصري
دخل الى اراضي المعارضه من اراضي النظام
اشاره ايجابيه خبرنا عن حجم هذا الفريق
واين يتوزع ويتركز الان العمل جمعه
يعني هذا الفريق مقسم الى قسمين فريق
متخصص في الالقاب سوف يساعد فرق الدفاع
المدني في مساله البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاذ وهناك فريق طبي مؤلفا مجموعه من
الاطباء
يعني هؤلاء الاطباء لديهم اختصاصات يعني
مطلوبه في داخل السوري اجراء عمليات
جراحيه دقيقه هذا الفريق دخل الى مدينه
حلب من مناطق النظام وعلى الاغلب سيتجه
يعني سيكون خط مساره بلده جنديرس التي
تشهد يعني اكبر عدد من الوفيات وفيات
ارتفع الى 600 قتيل وهو العدد الاكبر على
مستوى سوريا في بلده واحده
وايضا قد يساعد المشافي الاخرى المشفى خاص
بمشفى تشرين عفوا مشفى عفرين
العسكري وقد ينتقل ربما الى مشفى ادب
المركزي فيه ايضا اعداد كبيره
المصابين كما قلت ميسون يشكل هذا دخول هذا
الفريق امل جديد لدى يعني الماسورين
العالقين يعني السوريين المنكوبين في
مناطق المعارضه بان يتبعوا فرق اخرى ويمهد
ايضا لدخول المساعدات من المعابر التي ظلت
مغلقه منذ ساعات السبعين الماضيه وحتى
الان بين مناطق التماس بين بين النظام
والمعارضه